[Musique]
mecheri vous savez l'année qu'on aille
où les gens pensaient qu'on ne
reviendrait plus tout si on les embête
si on dérange tous ces cons et appelle
belle au mélange
c'est pas compliqué lefebvre a jamais
sur aucun sujet mais c'est surtout pas
de nous censurer
la télé c'est quand la télé c'est roja
sera que tu es d'arcade pour cette
nouvelle année
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aïe
si on voulait
passée la mer
si vous êtes assez large
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
passée la rai
ici
rouge
[Applaudissements]
et là mais
on fait des départs et on écoute isa au
fond jamais jamais l'on ne comprend on
se charrie comme une vraie mamie on n'en
peut plus de jeu mais 22 janvier où on
est toutes les petits potins
mais notre jt sonné on peut les biens
xavier qui m'est fait nos ennemis c'est
pas compliqué ne fermera jamais sur
aucun sujet mais c'est
tout pas de loup s'en sert et la télé
c'est que d'annuler ce héros sera que tu
es d'arcade pour cette nouvelle
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aïe aïe
cd on vous aime
ouah c'est la mer
vous êtes
passer la main
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bahia
c
bassil
ma vie à toi mon papa je te préviens mon
ami je vais pas mais joe durie d entrer
dans ma vie en toi mon papa chez
je te préviens mon ami je pète pas comme
une star et
[Musique]
aïe
c'est rouge n
une fois c'est la mère
le seo vous elle
asselah
aïe aïe
c'est au bout j'ai
c'est là
aussi on vous aime
là c'est l'arrêt
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aïe
c'est au bout
[Applaudissements]
ces eaux
bah c'est la veille
[Applaudissements]